les images d'une aux interventions
policières très violent les victimes à
la peau noire
un homme rapidement rentrer chez lui
dans l'espoir d'éviter une amende parce
qu'il ne portait pas le masque
ils m'ont surpris ils m'ont fait peur je
me suis retourné j'ai vu un mec en civil
ensuite j'ai vu un policier coups de
poing de pied et de matraque
télescopique les agents le frappe durant
de longues minutes
on m'a agressé parce que il avait
autorité je n'ai rien fait du tout je
n'ai pas mis deux coups de poing je n'ai
rien fait du tout en plus des coûts il y
aurait eu des insultes des sales [ __ ]
plusieurs fois on me regarde dans les
yeux et en mettant des coups de poing
des images qui nous font honte lance le
président emmanuel macron
des images qui contredisent aussi les
explications des policiers et si on
n'avait pas cela malheureusement iv est
évidemment qui sera en détention parce
que c'est sa parole contre celle des
policiers et non sait parfaitement que
c'est celle des politiques qui
l'emporterait en tout quatre policiers
ont été suspendus et placé en garde à
vue
le ministre responsable et policiers
promet d'être intraitable lorsqu'il ya
des gens qui déconne ils doivent quitter
l'uniforme de la république ils doivent
être sanctionnés ils doivent quitter ce
travail un blâme rapide qui témoigne de
la nervosité du gouvernement
voici le résultat de ces textes de loi
est très controversée justement parce
qu'il pourrait limiter la capacité des
citoyens a filmé les policiers en plein
travail
depuis les chez les jaunes les
interventions policières violent
semblent se multiplier en france dans
les grandes manifestations comme lors
d'interactions banale qui tourne mal
ce député d'opposition en tire une
conclusion on n'est plus là sur quelque
chose d'accidentel on est quelque chose
ce que quelque chose de structurel qui
réclame un vrai projet pour la police
française c'est tout une affaire qui
ébranle le gouvernement français au
point de promettre de revoir certaines
dispositions du controversé et textes de
loi en attendant les policiers se
prépare à d'autres manifestations demain
ici annick dumont baron radio-canada
paris